ماذا تريد اسرائيل من وائل الدحدوح هي كما
يعرف الجميع دوله مدجج باسلحه الموت وقد
ارسلت جيشها الى قطاع غزه لتحقيق هدف
القضاء على حركه حماس واسترداد جنودها
الاسرى من هناك لكن حصاد قنابلها لم ينجز
في ازيد من ثلاثه شهور غير قتل الوف
المدنيين الابرياء
وهو على ما يعرف الجميع ايضا مراسل صحفي
لقناه الجزيره التي لا تملك من الاسلحه
غير الاقلام والكاميرات والميكروفونات بها
تنقل وينقل مراسلها ويوثق صور ما يحدث من
معارك ومذابح وتدمير جريا على ما تفعل
وسائل الاعلام منذ اول صحيفه في التاريخ
اما مرد السؤال الالف عما تبدو كانها قصه
ثار بين دوله ورجل فيعود الى استهداف جيش
الاحتلال حياه الدحدوح وحياه عائلته ثلاث
مرات متتاليه كان اخرها هذه التي اودت
بابنه البكر حمزه بعدما كانت الثانيه قد
اصيب فيها بجروح وقتلت زميله مصور قناه
الجزيره سامر ابو دقه في وقت لم تكن قد
مرت فيه سوى اسابيع قليله على دفن زوجته
وابنه وابنته وحفيده الذين قتلوا ومعهم
عدد من اقربائه في قصف
اسرائيلي انها الصدفه او الاضرار الجانبيه
للحرب قد يقول المدافعون عن الجريمه في
مرتها الاولى غير ان تكرارها على هذا
النحو سيجعل لها اسما اخر في راي سواهم
ممن يعتقدون بانها تعكس اصرارا على اخراس
الصحفيين الفلسطينيين في قطاع غزه او
تخييرهم بين الصمت والموت نظرا لنجاحهم في
كشف الزيف الروايات الاسرائيليه امام
الراي العام العالمي هذا اغتيال للكلمه
يستدرك الكثيرون وهم يشيرون الى ان قتل
حمزه الدحدوح ورفيقه مصطفى ثريا قد رفع
عدد شهداء الصحافه الفلسطينيين منذ بدء
الحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه الى 209
اي الى ما يفوق عدد امثالهم من الضحايا في
اي من الحروب التي عرفتها البشريه سقطوا
وسفح دمائهم على هذه الارض وكان احدا لم
يسمع بهذه الاخبار كان
احدا لم يرى ما يجري سيصبح وائل الدحدوح
والحال هذه مثالا ساطعا على الجريمه
المتسلسله ضد الصحفيين الفلسطينيين وبرفض
الصمت واسراره على البقاء امام الكاميرا
ليقوم بواجبه المهني والانساني بعد كل
كارثه تحل به سيصبح نموذجا يختزل روايه
الفلسطينيه لا اله الا الله لا اله
الا منذ 76 سنه تدفن فلسطين ابنائها الذين
يقتلون برصاص الغزات ثم تنهض من جديد
لتعلن استعصاء قضيتها على مشاريع التصفيه
ووائل الدحدوح كذلك